[Musique]
un mois après les inondations qui ont
ravagé cette région du sud du Pakistan
des zones entières restent largement
sinistrées pour accéder aux villages
encore coupé du monde nous devons
emprunter un bateau et naviguer sur cet
océan d'eau stagnante
au plus fort de la crise
il y avait 6 à 9 mètres d'eau
aujourd'hui il en reste encore quatre
employé de l'Office des forêts il
connaît cette région Parker et tient à
nous montrer l'ampleur des dégâts
regardez ici c'était une mosquée elle
est sous l'eau et derrière il y avait
une école primaire qui est aussi inondée
dans ce village vivait 200 familles qui
ont dû tout abandonner
déserté il ne reste plus ici que des
ruines
nous ne croisons que ces deux hommes
deux frères les seuls à être revenus on
est là pour récupérer la ferraille de
notre maison on va la mettre de côté
pourquoi on pourra reconstruire
fin août en pleine nuit ils étaient chez
eux quand l'eau a commencé à monter
l'eau est arrivée du village d'à côté
elle est entrée si vite à cause de la
pluie nous étions déjà un peu inondés
mais là ça a tout détruit on a dû
envoyer nos familles dans un endroit
plus sûr
depuis le début des inondations plus de
33 millions de personnes ont dû fuir
leur maison c'est l'équivalent de la
moitié de la population française tout
autour du plus grand lac du pays qui
débordent encore
des camps de déplacés gigantesques
continuent d'accueillir des familles qui
attendent la décrue sous la chaleur et
dans une extrême promiscuité cet homme
vit sous sa tente depuis plus d'un mois
avec sa femme et ses cinq enfants
ici nous avons nos habits
et là ce sont nos draps
c'est tout ce que nous avons apporté de
notre village on a tout perdu avec les
inondations sur les milliers de familles
installées ici tout ou presque compte au
moins un enfant malade à cause des
obstacles Nantes les épidémies
prolifèrent nek Mohamed lui est inquiet
pour ses filles ma fille elle paludisme
c'est le médecin qui me l'a dit et mon
autre fille là-bas aussi a de la fièvre
on nous a donné des médicaments mais ça
ne retombe pas il y a tellement de gens
qui sont malades ici
avec la mort de la décrue certains
villages les plus surélevés émergent
enfin celui-ci a vu revenir la semaine
dernière trois familles dont celle de
Miran rind avant il y avait une maison
ici mais à son retour il a surtout
trouvé des amas de décombres vous voyez
ces briques toutes ces briques ce sont
celles des murs de l'habitation qu'il y
avait ici ce village avait déjà été
touché par les terribles inondations de
2010 mais celle d'août dernier ont été
pour lui d'une intensité incomparable en
2010 on n'avait pas eu autant de pertes
l'eau était déjà montéo mais là c'est
gigantesque je n'avais rien vu de pierre
si certains habitants retrouvent leur
maison les champs alentours eux sont
toujours submergés cette agriculteur est
désespéré après un épisode de sécheresse
au printemps dernier il comptait sur
cette saison pour planter du blé
ici c'était mes terres
mais avec toutes ces eaux je ne peux
rien faire
et les autorités pakistanaises ils vont
encore falloir attendre au moins un mois
avant que la situation ne revienne à la
normale